also ich glaube ein basalen Sieg will ja
niemand und es war sicherlich auch
richtig zu Beginn auch zu helfen aber
die Frage ist wie geht es jetzt weiter
ja also ich glaube diese verhärteten
Positionen von denen sie sprechen das
sollen wir auch hier auch
zusammenfinden also mir viel ein wenn
ich noch mal das ist schon diese
Extremposition das ist so ein Stichwort
für mich in der corona-krise hieß es
jedes Menschenleben was Corona zum Opfer
fällt ist eins zu viel Freiheit ist
nichts
Leben ist alles und jetzt haben wir
genau den das Gegenteil das Leben ist
nichts hunderttausend die sterben müssen
egal ob es geht um die Freiheit und ich
würde sagen wie sie die die die Wahrheit
dazwischen ja Verteidigung ja klar
natürlich helfen wir natürlich ist
Russland der böse Aggressor ja
aber die Wahrheit liegt dazwischen wann
ist es Zeit mal an den Verhandlungstisch
zu gehen und Frieden und Verhandlungen
in den Vordergrund zurück
hier ist ja das Problem dass viele sagen
es gibt keinen möglichen
Verhandlungstisch also das ist ja immer
das das gegen der Gegenpunkt der kommt
dass es nicht möglich ist mit Putin zu
verhandeln aber darüber haben sie ja
auch den Beitrag geschrieben zum
Beispiel in der Süddeutschen Zeitung
dass sie eher empfinden das auch eine
gewisse Kriegslust herrscht also beiden
hat ja heute auch positive Signale dazu
geäußert also ich bin jetzt heute wieder
ganz optimistisch gesehen ja aber zurück
zu meiner These ja die Intellekt ja also
das ist mein Milieu über das ich spreche
dass mich auch persönlich wirklich
enttäuscht hat nicht alle intellektuell
ich will jetzt keine intellektuellen
Bashing machen aber es ist doch eine
mächtige Gruppe und wir schauen zurück
in die Geschichte gut es wird immer vom
Ersten Weltkrieg erzählt es wurde auch
von Historikern aufgearbeitet das
Künstler denke intellektuelle da eine
negative Rolle gespielt haben und sich
haben verleiten lassen in den 68ern war
das auch da ist eine gute Idee die aber
dann verhärtet irgendwann zu einer
Ideologie wird man kann sich fragen
warum ist es so
ist es dass das auch nie die Langeweile
des das geschützten Lebens man sehnt
sich nach dem echten Leben oder ist es
gar eine Krise der Männlichkeit
wäre vielleicht auch möglich in den
westlichen Staaten die dann dazu
verleitet dass man gewisse Dinge sehr
idealisiert auch die Ukraine nicht als
topografische Ort der angegriffen wird
aber als Ort wir haben es gerade gehört
der Demokratie ich meine das Ranking war
jetzt nicht ideal ja damit will ich
nicht sagen dass Russland das irgendwas
in irgendeiner Weise rechtfertigt ist
aber wir dürfen auch nicht idealisieren
der Ukraine hat sich ja in den letzten
Jahren aber auch viel verändert wenn man
auch mit Blick auf die Demokratie schaut
die die Frage die ich mir gestellt habe
Frau Weinfeld ich habe ihr ich habe das
mit sehr großen Interesse gelesen
sollten sich denn überhaupt
Intellektuelle zum Krieg äußern das war
meine Frage erstmal und dann habe ich
gedacht vielleicht haben diese
Intellektuellen keine Kriegslust sondern
einfach Bewunderung empfunden für
Menschen die ihr Land verteidigen für
Frauen das war auch ein Beispiel die an
die Front gehen weil sie in Freiheit
leben wollen vielleicht ist es auch
einfach Bewunderung habe ich gedacht ja
wobei ich dann wieder zu dem zurückkehre
was ich eben gesagt habe
Freiheit ist wichtig ja natürlich aber
sind wir dafür bereit ja breit und Leben
wirklich alles zu geben ja
Grenzen ich rede nicht von alternativen
ich rede von dem dazwischen
jagenfreiheit oder leben das ist die
falsche Alternative die Toten von
Butcher die haben mit ihrer Freiheit
auch ihr Leben verloren und das gilt für
Hunderttausende für Millionen in den
heute besetzten Gebieten ganz genauso
dass die von genau dieser Art von
Vernichtung von Tod bedroht sind von
Vertreibung und von Ermordung davon von
der Entführung ihrer Kinder all diese
Dinge passieren dafür da sind Freiheit
und leben Synonyme man kann nicht das
eine haben
das Andere entscheiden der Sicherheit
immer weitermachen genau deswegen sie
wollen das Morgen nicht ich auch nicht
der Krieg ist das schlimmste was
passieren kann wir sehen es ja gerade
deswegen es kann nicht sein dass der
einzige Weg ist zu sagen mir kann ich
mit Putin verhandeln es geht nicht es
geht nicht anscheinend geht es doch es
kommen hoffnungsvolle Signale aus den
USA heute ja und anscheinend wenn man
den Gerüchten glaubt das sind jetzt die
Quellen Wale ja auch schon mal was ja
das muss in den Fokus rücken Paul du
bist uns ja auch noch zugeschaltet den
Text kennst du wahrscheinlich aber was
ich besonders hier finde einen Tisch ist
zeigt schon sehr klar die Stimmung in
diesem Land in Deutschland auf es wurde
gerade gesagt es gibt hoffnungsvolle
Anzeichen für Verhandlungen wie nimmst
du das wahr
ich sehe diese hoffnungsvollen Anzeichen
nicht zumindest nicht hier in der
Ukraine da ist man fest gewillt zu sagen
wir holen uns unser Land weiter zurück
noch einmal
er fällt heute das ja gerade klar
gemacht es geht nicht darum ob hier
irgendjemand für ein Freiheitskampf
gefeiert wird sondern diejenigen die
dort kämpfen kämpfen für ihre
Mitmenschen um sie zu befreien um sie zu
retten um dafür zu sorgen dass diese
horror-taten die in diesem Gebieten
passieren aufhören das ist der Grund
warum die Ukraine kämpft und ihr Land
zurückerobern will und das hat nichts
mit dem einen Sinne da ist irgendetwas
heroisches zu dem jetzt intellektuelle
aufschauen und auf der anderen Seite
sind die Soldaten nein das ist der
völlig falsche Ansatz was Verhandlungen
angeht ja es gab am Anfang am zu Beginn
des Krieges diese Versuche dann
passierten Dinge wie in Butcher dann
passierten weitere Kriegsverbrechen dann
hat hatte ich mir Putin gesagt das sind
jetzt meine Gebiete das ist jetzt mein
Russland also hat illegale Referenten
dort stattfinden lassen so unter welchen
Voraussetzungen soll denn würde mir
selenski sich mit Wladimir Putin
momentan an einen Tisch setzen das
funktioniert nicht es funktioniert auch
nicht innerhalb der Ukraine weil die
Ukraine dann gegen selensky
wahrscheinlich Aufstehen würden und
sagen moment mal es sind so viele
Menschen gestorben
wir wollen dass dieses Land unseres
bleibt befreit bleibt und dann die
zweite ganz ganz wichtige Sache bei der
Frage der Verhandlung und was ein Grund
ist warum die Ukraine sagt wir müssen
diesen Krieg gewinnen und wir müssen
diesen Krieg zu Ende führen der Krieg
hat ja schon mal begonnen 2014 eben im
Ostteil des Landes und wir haben dann
erlebt dass Russland immer weitergemacht
hat und die große Sorge der Ukraine ist
und ich glaube die ist sehr berecht wenn
man jetzt eine Art Waffenstillstand
machen würde jetzt ausgerechnet jetzt wo
die Ukraine sozusagen am Vorteil sind im
Osten und im Süden dann würde Russland
sich weiter bewaffnen würde sozusagen
die militärproduktion weiter auffahren
würde eine Mobilisierung professioneller
hinbekommen und das würde bedeuten in
wenigen Monaten oder auch einem Jahr
würde man wieder versuchen Kiew
anzugreifen es ist ja nicht so dass ich
putinsil verändern würde weil es ist im
putin ist kein Verhandlungspartner er
hat alles gebrochen er hat vor dem Krieg
gesagt er wird die Ukraine nicht
angreifen er hat Versprechungen gemacht
er hat gelogen er hat all das getan
weshalb man sagen muss selbst wenn er
jetzt sagen würde wir setzen uns
gemeinsam hin und wir wir versuchen
jetzt hier eine Lösung zu finden das
würde bedeuten die Ukraine Wissen in
wenigen Monaten greift er wieder an